hey who's house dre's house that super
bowl halftime show reintroduce the world
to the wild wild west welcome to
entertainment tonight y'all it was truly
a moment and can we just say that stars
were everywhere everywhere and what
those icons did on that halftime stage
was nothing short of what's historic
come on
you notice everyone in here was rapping
along singing along absolutely everybody
was in it these are records that
everybody loves period
bieber wrapped along with eminem
bennefer jammed in the stands jay-z and
beyonce in sync and kanye loving snoop i
saw
drake walking in those blue sweatsuits
was he on the field
and he could be anywhere he wants and i
still got love for the streets fans
today are calling the hip-hop icons the
new avengers and here's what you didn't
see at halftime i took this video
backstage of performers just moments
before they hit the stage we've been in
hard rehearsals probably for the last
three weeks the biggest challenge
executive producer jessie collins told
me it was getting the show down to 14
minutes i mean you got monster catalogs
and trying to figure out how to make
this work where you're getting just
enough everything that we can fit in was
really really hard we are a family snoop
dogg today at the opening of his new
store spoke to hip hollywood it just all
came together with the culmination of
all the people that was up there another
highlight eminem taking a knee despite
the headline saying the nfl told him not
to an nfl spokesperson tells us we
watched every rehearsal this week and
that element was included as for
surprise performer 50 cent everyone's
talking about his upside-down spider-man
move and homage to this music video and
only e.t has mary jay's fashion secrets
[Music]
we're leaving everything on the stage we
started with five looks this one has a
twin and another color
and
we landed with this one mary j stylist
jason rembert gave us a close-up look at
the grammy winners sparkling leopard
print outfit and blinged out micro
shorts you probably won't even notice it
but there's like a mic pack sleeve on
the back of the suit that's also
encrusted and the same material in those
thigh high boots jason added a little
something extra i gave her a grip on the
bottom of the shoe that tarp that they
put down on the field is extremely
slippery speaking of fashion check out
50s insta today you can get a tank top
just like the one he wore at halftime
for 39.99
former halftime show performer j.lo was
living her best life with ben affleck in
the vip suites while her ex a-rod was
also in the
stands but before the game ben scored
big with an early valentine's day gift
for j.lo
ben directed a video of j-lo's single on
my way featuring vintage shots of
benefer from their first relationship a
source tells e.t ben and jen are open to
the possibility of getting engaged and
married ben's kids really like jen and
her kids love bed
[Music]
but we're wondering how does jlo feel
about this ben's very steamy new trailer
for his movie deep water with ex anna de
armas dropped today why are you the only
man who wants to stay with me
oh
who did kim kay's ex kanye take to the
game their kids eight-year-old north and
six-year-old saint yay was in his
signature full face mask and in good
spirits in our pre-game exclusive kanye
how are you
how are you doing today oh what up baby
how you been
good you with the babies today
enjoy enjoy
we got good seats dorothy
kanye got some heat for covering his
face some fans noting he paid 50 000
bucks for a ticket to watch it like this
even judd apatow who was sitting behind
kanye posted he seems very hot and
sweaty in the mask yay spent a lot of
the day on a social media tirade posting
over a dozen times taking aim at kim and
boyfriend pete davidson calling him
skeet and posting a civil war mock-up
that included now ex-girlfriend julia
fox e.t has learned the couple has
already called the quits a rep for julia
tells e.t they remain good friends and
collaborators as for kim and pete they
were unfazed on back-to-back date nights
in new york this happened they just
kissed i think yep their first public
kiss a source tells e.t the couple isn't
afraid to show pda he's so tall and very
protective of her she loves to hang on
to him kanye who has since deleted most
of his posts did point out that he
bought kim the coat that she was wearing
on one of the dates this morning he said
i have faith that we'll be back together
and later posted this a truck full of
roses e.t has learned were delivered to
kim's house my vision is crystal clear
[Applause]
back at the game yay's one-time rival
drake was also among the stars packing
the stands and getting excited
i love mary j i love everybody
performing snoop kendrick
it's the hot knife all of y'all gray
snoop dogg i'm proud of him
the snoop is here big for the weed game
is going down only e.t was hanging with
the celebs going solo and the couple's
cramming into sophie stadium we're all
cincinnati man the upset is gonna happen
no i'm good with whatever house divided
deb how are you brother kendall jenner
arrived with her man nba superstar devin
booker getting in a double date with
eminem fan justin bieber and white haley
cardi b sang along to mary j with hubby
offset and yup that's her hustler's
co-star j-lo sneaking into the selfie it
was clearly parent's day out
joe jonas and his eminem stan wife
sophie turner left daughter willa at
home as rumors swirled they could be
giving her a sibling and check out
olivia munn and john mulaney a source
tells e.t the mom and dad to baby
malcolm were also up in the suites
enjoying their sunday fun day
this dad prince harry wasn't with wife
megan but did have cousin eugenie by his
side harry was also snapped inside with
national anthem performer mickey guyton
who tweeted he was quote just lovely i
even curtsied in my tracksuit and from
the prince to a king lebron big day ohio
in the house
everybody was letting loose while
beyonce dazzled in diamonds and daisy
dukes proud dad jay-z caught this shot
of blue ivy midair on the field and then
there's the cordon family not james his
parents a rams fan of bengals fan what's
going on we have to support opposing
teams for the last four super bowls that
we've covered
my team has won it's going to be the
exception this year rams are gonna win
i gotta win from the stands to the field
the rock was on hand to introduce the
two teams and hype up the crowd
it is time
for the super bowl
this is a dream come true for me you
know my goal was to play in the nfl and
that never came true so here i am on
this super bowl field it's going to be
amazing just before dwayne's pump up
speech mickey guyton performed the
national anthem
i think everybody would love to perform
at the super bowl i just never thought
it was a possibility for me we talked to
mickey last week and she had the cutest
interview crasher what is kitty's name
shut up
well mickey's rendition caught the eye
of the og halle berry she posted mickey
guyton that's the tweet
one super bowl mishap mickey was id'd
incorrectly as janae aiko who sang
america the beautiful earlier it was a
special moment for the la native
and after four years apart mary mary
reunited to perform
[Music]
i caught up with the grammy-winning
sister duo who grew up in inglewood
after they hit the stage how was that
moment for you literally this morning i
said lord let me allow myself to
experience every moment of this i just
think the word that would sum this up
that's for me is grateful
for the victorious ram fam and girl data
4 quarterback matthew stafford the win
was especially sweet his wife and former
college sweetheart kelly is now fully
recovered after surgery for a
non-cancerous brain tumor three years
ago she's been with me
through all these years and we've
battled so many things together
it was a super bowl baby boy for wide
receiver van jefferson right after the
victory van rushed straight to be with
his wife samaria who went into labor
during the game and left on a stretcher
my wife is having a baby tonight
daddy to be odell beckham jr kissed
girlfriend lauren woods baby bump while
donning 200 000 cleats studded with 1500
diamonds and it was a diamond ring that
ram's safety taylor rap gave girlfriend
danny johnson
but it was the bengals blues for
quarterback joe burrow despite coming
back from this frightening moment which
had girlfriend olivia holsemaker and his
parents worried joe cool almost pulled
off the upset of course his fashion
didn't disappoint he arrived and left in
this swank black and white tiger stripe
suit and black hat it stings but you
know we had a great year
[Music]